[Music]
I was just sitting at home doing CHS he
wanted me to list out exactly all the
things that I was doing my gut tells me
there's something very wrong here am I
in emotionally abusive and controlling
relationship or is this all just a
misunderstanding and I'm actually the
[Music]
problem what is going on this is John
with the Dr John deloney
show one of the top 500 greatest mental
health and marriage and parenting and
emotional and mental health podcasts
ever and mental health and we also
discuss Mental Health on this
show going to keep saying it dude I'm so
glad that you've joined us um over the
last six months the show has been on
such a Skyrocket we've got a whole bunch
of new people with us and I'm so
grateful that you're here I'm so
grateful that you are giv us your most
precious resource your time the show is
real people going through real hard
stuff trying to figure out what to do in
their marriages with their kids with
their kids schools with their mental and
emotional health and I'm so grateful
that you've joined us if you want to be
on this show talk to a neutral third
party I may not have the answer but I
promise I'll sit with you and we'll
figure out what's going on go to
johal.com d l n johal.com
askas or give me a buzz at 1844 693 3291
leave a message and we'll get back to
you and if Jenna selects the call she'll
give you a shout we'll put it on the
show and we will rock it on till the
break it Dawn don't
forget
um it's almost Thanksgiving go to
john.com get your questions for humans
right now I'm Gonna Save Your
Thanksgiving on a savior Christmas
there's decks for couples there's decks
for kids there's specific decks for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and new this
year Well Thanksgiving Christmas ones
are new but we also have grandparents
and grandkids so look go to Thanksgiving
and go on a date for the first time in
months and leave your kids with your
grandparents and know they're not going
to get their heads pumped full of
conspiracy theories or some political
lunacy I got you they can just go
through these cards they're gonna have a
great time your kids are going to learn
about your parents and probably learn
some things that you didn't even know
and vice versa go to john.com pick up
questions for humans they're the best
seller out of the store and they're
going to change your relationships for
the better all right let's go out to
Bend Oregon not bend over but Bend
Oregon and talk to Elise what's up
Elise hi Dr John um doing good hi Dr
John can you hear me doing good I can
yeah I can hear you
great
okay so um I appreciate you taking my
call I've been really stressed for the
past year it seems like um what's going
on my my question is am I in a
emotionally abusive relationship and
controlling relationship or is this all
just a misunderstanding and I'm actually
the problem okay hold on before you ask
I want to know what you think
actually not even what you think like
put your hand on your on your belly
right now on your tummy what does your
gut tell
you um my gut tells me there's something
very wrong here but I keep holding on to
Maybe not maybe I
just don't know what a good relationship
should be like ah okay so before you
tell me what's going
on
have you ever had reason to doubt
you
um in yeah in relationships absolutely
okay so your self-doubt is is well
earned you've made mistakes in the past
and you don't think you're very
trustworthy right
now
um just maybe my level of maturity or um
how I react to situations might be my my
biggest issue that I need to work on
okay that's super fair man that's very
self-aware of you that's awesome all
right so what's going on that you're
wondering am I the
problem
so um I've been with my boyfriend for a
year and a half um he's very very
attentive which is one of the things
that Drew me to him I don't think guys
are usually that attentive as he is um
so I felt for the lucky like as the
luckiest girl
alive um for a while um but a little bit
into dating
um
he I I guess I wouldn't communicate with
him enough and by that I mean I would
wake up in the morning and go to work
sometimes and I wouldn't say good
morning right away I would say good
morning at 9:00 a.m. instead of 8 or
instead of at 7 when I woke up and um
were you are youall living together or
were you were just in your own apartment
and you just go to
work yeah just in my own apartment and I
would go to work you know just going
about normal life things and
um he needs to be in constant constant
communication constant communication
like the moment I wake up I need to talk
to him and um uh early on in our
relationship he almost broke up with me
because he said he felt like an
afterthought and to me that was wild
because he's the only person that I
would spend any time with we would see
each other almost every day I would
communicate text with him you know daily
constantly and so when he told me that
and he was about to break up with me
because he felt like an afterthought I
tripled down on the amount of um
attention that I would give him you know
and I just made sure that I was in
constant communication I mean every 5 to
10 minutes I kid you not um to me it
seems excessive but I thought okay maybe
if I do this he'll feel a little bit
more secure in the relationship he's
been burned before he's been cheated on
y y so I want to make him feel secure
and see that I'm all in that I'm all
about him and he doesn't have to worry
um but after a while he he moved the
Finish Line
right I'm sorry he just moved the finish
line yes yeah after a while I noticed
not that it just no matter how much
effort I would put in he would still be
like really suspicious of me of
everything that I would do and even if
he knew I was at home just sitting at
home doing chores or whatever he wanted
me to list out exactly all the things
that I was doing at least run run run
run and I hate to say that to you
because I know that you like this person
and I know that you're invested in this
person I wish you could see the eyes of
the women that are looking at me right
now they look like saucers
like wide
eyy that's what everybody tells me yes
and here here's what I want to here's
the most important thing about what
you're what what you're walking through
and it has absolutely nothing to do with
him okay I want to take him completely
out of
it especially in the first six months
you really liked this guy didn't you
yeah absolutely like you grew really you
yeah you started making plans with this
guy like secretly right you had like you
started developing pictures of oh this
is going to be like
right yeah and you expressed that in a
way that was whole and good for
you you really fell for
somebody yeah and they looked at you and
said you're not
enough the way way you feel whole and
good is not enough for
me you have to be
more yeah and I'm talking about um this
could be text messages you have to text
me 15 times a day I text you five times
a day I text nobody in my life nobody
and I text you
five right 20 minutes go by and he'll
question it that's right and that can be
sexual that can be Financial that can be
um
questioning every second of you like
everything about you and the reason like
when you said I tripled down and I kind
of held my breath because I was almost
positive what was going to happen if it
had been
you now here's like uh the push back I'm
going to get from people listening is
this when I got married to my
wife I didn't know certain things I
didn't know you have to wash your sheets
once a month good grief are we crazy
right I didn't know
and my wife told
me like hey in my house we're going to
wash our sheets every week cuz you're
gross and I was like okay
awesome and I came towards right there
was a Finish Line there this is what
we're going to do and I was like awesome
I'm in
it when you said you triped
down he moved the Finish Line on you all
right fine I'm going to text you 15
times a day and then within a week or
two 15 times isn't enough now I want to
see your text I want to GPS locate you
on my phone I want because what he's
trying to do is use you to fill some
sort of void he's
got yep you are a drug you're a Xanax
for him and he's got to keep taking more
and more and more and more and he
doesn't care if it kills you in the
process
that's what it feels like definitely it
is and I could hear you talking as you
don't talk about this enough out loud
with your friends because I could hear
as you were talking it was finally all
starting to come out a little bit
right yeah I've started hiding it from
people the extent of it please don't
please don't can I ask you
why um like let's say let's say you call
him today and break
up and there's that deep grief
what do you what's scary about that
moment for you because it's deeper than
just a breakup for
you
um uh I don't know just I was just
really holding on to the idea that I
could have something good with him but
sometimes I think if we were to break up
I would be a lot I would be hurting for
a while but I'd ultimately be doing a
lot
better do you believe
that because I think you're worth a lot
better whatever that looks
like yeah and I'm telling you to run I'm
not in the business of breaking up
relationships and so if you want to stay
here's your only path
forward a sitdown conversation where you
say I love you we've been together for a
year and a
half and a you've got to go do your own
work because I can't be responsible for
making you feel better it's not my
job number two I will text you three
times a day period and if that's not
good enough for you then we're done then
you are choosing to not be in
relationship with
me I will tell you where I'm like when
I'm headed out with my friends you're
not going to geolocate me on your
phone you're not going to come by my
house in the middle of the night and
check on my car you're not going to go
through my text and you're not going to
go through my
receipts and if that's not okay if you
need that to be whole then you're
choosing to not be in relationship with
me because I can't live like
this because you're like being you're
like being like your your dating
relationship is like a I was watching
Homeland last week when I was sick like
it's it's like a CIA investigation all
the time 247 365 those are exhausting
right yeah I'm under
scrutiny yeah have you have you cheated
on him Elise no no are you hiding money
from him absolutely not I don't believe
you of course you're not
right and you should not have to spend
every second of your life as though you
are
you get to decide whether I'm staying or
going I'm going to ask you with all my
heart I'm not going to beg you but I'm
going to get really
close you know you're in an unsafe
relationship whether it's physical
whether it's sexually unsafe or whether
it is psychologically or emotionally
unsafe when you start when you start
hiding parts of it from your closest
friends when you stop telling the truth
to the people who you know have your
best interest at
heart when you have that little flash of
I think everything in my life would be
better it would suck for a while but
everything in my life would be better if
this was if this was
gone I want you to put your hand on your
belly and feel that and believe it
because I think you're
right I think you're right and if you
choose to stay I want you to be really
honest about what you need not the
triple down version plus the triple
downtimes 2 * 8 not that version I want
you to be really firm about what you
believe and what you need to be whole
and I want you to put that on the table
and say this is who you're
with this is what I'm worth and this is
what I need I can't keep living under an
investigation under
microscope and maybe he'll go oh my gosh
you're right I'm going to go to
counseling and I'm going to get better
but I think you and I both know probably
not make a call but I want you to make
the call knowing
this you're worth something better than
what you're experiencing right
now and I hope for the first time in a
long time you'll listen to that voice
way down deep trying to keep Elise
safe and reach out to your friends and
start telling them the truth hey guys
this isn't getting better it's actually
getting worse I need somebody to hold my
hand through this process cuz I think
it's going to be kind of
Rocky but you're being loved and that
means you're worth being
whole and you're worth telling the truth
we'll be right
back hey delone here good folks our
society has devalued sleep we're told to
keep working and grind through the
fatigue and pretend that we don't need
sleep then this crazy culture tries to
shame us when we do hit the sack at a
normal time I'm here to tell you 7 to9
hours of refreshing sleep is essential
for all aspects of your physical
physical and mental health and to help
with that I recommend investing in an
amazing mattress getting great sleep is
priceless but a premium mattress can
cost a lot and that's a big reason why I
love dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses
are made with premium materials for half
the cost of other premium mattresses
they use Advanced Technologies to keep
you comfortable all night for a great
price and the exclusive deal they're
offering my listeners can help even more
right now dreamcloud is offering my
listeners 40 % off all mattresses plus
an additional $50 discount go to
dreamcloud sleep.com and enter code John
deloney today that's dreamcloud
sleep.com with code John
deloney all right let's go out to Fort
Worth
Texas oh home of the Rangers and talk to
Christopher what's up
Christopher hello Don can you hear me I
can what's up
man hey um this is my first time on the
show been a long time listening um
pretty nervous but um we'll see how how
this how this goes hey I specifically
told the team no calls from the Dallas
Fort Worth area this week because you
guys just knocked out my Astros out of
the World
Series but yeah they said this one was
important so here we go what's up
man um yeah so um so this question is um
is in regards to just just I'm not sure
this like a personality issue or just
something I'm overthinking um as an
adult I was inspired by one of your
calls um in the past week stating that
it's hard to make friends as a as an
adult which is true it's the worst a
little yeah tell me about it um just to
give you a quick story I just recently
started a job and I want to be more
outgoing more friendly and stuff like
that for so I want to meet co-workers so
I want to meet co-workers just expand my
network but honestly it's so hard it's
so hard to network to make conversation
in the workplace and you know just it's
just really difficult um honestly I
really I have I have possibly like one
or two friends but then again when I
call them they always seem to be busy so
honestly I don't I wouldn't say that
have like a close circle of friends so
it's pretty hard to to just get out
there and just um expand myself and
expand my nck work so I just want to see
in your perspective how how can I
overcome this um obstacle man that's a
great question dude
um couple of thoughts here so how long
you been working at this new
place yeah I just recently started um
about I will say it makes it more
difficult because honestly my department
is mostly
for out middle age to to older women and
I'm a young male so oh yeah Christopher
oh yeah I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding so so honestly I'm not sure what
to what to bring up in a conversation
when they're talking about family stuff
like this I'm I'm not sure what to go on
from there I just I just I'm probably
just the one employee or coor that just
sits back and laugh and then if if I
have like a opinion or something then I
stay my opinion but I want to be more
more out there more more connections
more more conversations and stuff like
that I love that so A couple of
different things circle in my mind here
okay when it comes to making new friends
as an
adult the only two things I can think of
and I actually it's funny you mentioned
this I um I just
I got like an obnoxious amount of
Journal articles like nerd scientific
research articles I want to figure out
like everything about friendship because
I don't know how it works and so I'm
with you like I'm trying to figure this
out and I'm going to go down a rabbit
hole for a while I'm figuring it out for
the next several months I just want to
learn everything about it because I'm so
perplexed by it but the only thing I've
got for you right now when it comes to
just globally speaking about making new
friends as an
adult is three things number one go
first number two just make peace with
being weird number three be
hospitable and so if you sit back and
wait it's going to always it it's going
to feel like it never
comes and then if it does if it does
come you're on somebody else's
terms so you work in an office with four
or five or 10 or 15 middle-aged women
cool announce hey I want to go to lunch
with four or five of y'all and I want
you to teach me your secrets I'm buying
that's the hospitality part and it's
going to be expensive the first time but
I want you to take them out and here's a
magic thing so it's be weird go first be
hospitable hospitable mean hey I'm
having a Halloween get together at my
house I'd love to have y'all
come in your particular situation that's
that might not work that might be kind
of weird right um it might work at your
local church it might work at your local
like I don't know what hobbies you're
into and you might be like I don't have
any hobbies well it might be time to
like go take Jiu-Jitsu or go take a
welding class or go do some things that
are going to put you with other people
in your age demographic Etc okay but
when it comes to work when it comes to
meeting new people go first be weird and
be hospitable just have them over well I
got a little bitty apartment it's kind
of weird have them over anyway the only
time I would say don't have them over is
if you still live at your mom's house
okay that could be super weird
right in your
situation I have found one of the
greatest gifts we can give another
person is to ask about their life and to
listen to
them and so when they're talking about
family and you're just sitting back
cracking up you're laughing
instead of trying to think of the right
thing to add to the conversation the
right thing to
say when somebody's talking about their
dingdong husband did this again I can't
believe that a great gift you could give
them is to say hey I'm young are you
single Chris are you
single oh I'm sorry um yes yes I am okay
perfect hey I'm young and single how did
that guy get somebody as beautiful and
awesome as you I want to hear your story
and just let it go okay okay and what
you're doing is giving somebody an
opportunity to tell their story and they
might smile the whole time because
they're going to remember back to when
she actually liked her husband or their
romance story or she's going to get
choked up because the marriage is over
the guy passed away here was the story
from the past but you are letting them
you providing them an opportunity to get
in touch with some important feelings in
their life and that makes you a really
valuable human
being okay and whenever they talk
instead of leaning back which you
probably do I want you to consciously
Lean Forward on one elbow just a little
bit and it's going to feel awkward but I
want you to lean towards them a little
bit because that tells their body this
guy's safe and he's
listening okay okay think to ask more
questions than think what's the right
thing to say
here okay yeah and and also to add um
yeah that that that's great advice um
yeah I tried so hard to just search up
articles YouTube videos and stuff like
that but honestly um I I'm not I'm not
sure if you know I'm just I'm just
trying to find what to say and what
what's a good conversation starter
everybody likes to talk about
themsel okay
everybody okay and also to add also want
to expand like as as I mentioned like my
department mostly consists of of ladies
also want to expand to other department
but I'm not sure since since I'm not in
depart in their department and uh I
really don't understand what what they
do for work um I'm not sure that's it
yeah want that's it that's your
question hey can I take you to coffee
and just learn about what y'all
do uh what hey I'm over in Department X
I'm surrounded by like 35 middle-aged
women I want to learn about what you
guys are doing over here in this part of
the company can I buy you coffee okay
and what you're doing is not like hey
man will you come be my friend because
that's weird right that would make you
weird or hey you want to go talk about
chicks I don't know what weird weird
thing you're going to get on the
internet I guess this is going on the
internet so that might be a weird thing
but sitting down and asking somebody
dude so tell me like what do yall do
over here in this in this part of the
company and letting him talk and then
say are you married well yeah how'd that
happen happened
man you got kids yeah I got two kids
dude what's the best part of being a dad
like I'm not a dad yet what's the
scariest part of being a dad and you're
going to look up and you're going to
have spent an hour and that person has
mostly talked about
themsel and you've given them such a
gift to clarify what they love about
their job or to be honest about what
they don't like about their job to talk
about possibly their favorite thing
which is their wife or their kids or to
clarify some things struggling with at
home which might be their wife and their
kids but it's going in there to ask
questions and the question you just
asked I don't know who told you bro that
your questions aren't good but you just
told me like I don't even know what they
do over there awesome go ask them they
would love to tell you and if they don't
if they're like yeah I'm not going to
coffee with you minion you do not want
to spend two seconds with them they're
not worth your
time okay all right and let me leave you
with this
I don't know who in your life told you
that you're weird and don't aren't good
at having
friends but if you woke up how old are
you right
now I'm currently 25 okay you woke up
and you're 25 and you're looking around
and you don't have a ton of friends it's
not because you're weird or broken it's
because we've created a world where
friendships are so hard to come by and
they're so hard to keep they're
impossible
right yeah there's nothing wrong with
you brother you're not somehow broken
and you need to get on the internet and
figure out some
things you got to be weird you got to go
first you gotta be hospitable and you
got to say dude tell me about
you okay then eventually they're gonna
ask you like how did you come here and
then you can tell your story and now
y'all are having a
conversation okay sounds good yeah like
I said um I mean not just in a workplace
you know it's difficult but then even in
the outside world it's pretty scary
honestly um like I said I really don't I
really don't got much friends and you
always talk about having a close circle
around you honestly I feel like I don't
have that at all yeah um but yeah I gota
be you got to put yourself in that
position yeah you got to put yourself in
that world whether that's again signing
up for some
classes joining a running club taking
Jiu-Jitsu taking a woodworking class um
taking a drone flying I'm just making
stuff up but you got to put yourself in
a position to where you're going to run
into other people you can't just go to
work at 25 and then go home Scott
Galloway who um has got some great
messages he tells young people be at
home as little as possible you're 25
years old be at home as little as
possible continue to put yourself in
situations whether at your local church
joining a softball league soccer team uh
whatever put yourself in situations just
go if you're going to sit at home and
and read go do it in Starbucks you're
going to run into people and someone's
going to say hey can I borrow that chair
and you're like yeah you can sit down
here man where do you work and now
you're Off to the
Races but I don't want you to overthink
it and overthink it and overthink it and
overthink it but I do want you to start
putting yourself out there and the best
way to put yourself out there is to ask
tell me about you tell me about you and
I think you're going to find people love
talking about themselves and you're
going to give them a great gift which is
to feel things they haven't felt in a
long time cuz they've been sitting all
by themselves too you're awesome my
brother I want you to try this out for
like a month or two and then holler back
girl at me I ain't a holler back girl
holler back and let me know how it's
going I bet you the tide will begin to
turn you're awesome man talk to you soon
we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com /one today to start your free
trial just follow the simple prompts at
hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we are back hey I'm
excited about this I recently sat down
for an interview with my good
friend Dr Caroline
Leaf um she is brilliant brilliant
brilliant beyond all brilliant and she's
done some extraordinary research if
you're not following DR leaf you should
on the on the insta Tik toks on the what
do you call them the snap grams social
media social media yes you should follow
her on that um and pick up her books as
well but we had a long long conversation
together and so we'll release it over
the coming year but this particular
segment was important I asked her for
some explanation and some some
strategies for teaching kids
self-regulation something that's
increasingly important to me because I
got two kids in my house but also I'm
continually talking to parents about
working with their kids is how do we
teach kids what they're feeling and then
what to do
next because we have a whole generation
just look in Congress we have a whole
generation of adults who don't know how
to do this how do we stop that Madness
and teach this to kids here's what I'm
feeling here's what your body's doing
and then here's what to
next so here is a segment from my
conversation with the great Dr Caroline
leaf on teaching kids self-regulation
check it
out the most common question I
get Barun which is what about my
kids um kids are told by teachers you
have a this kids are sent out of their
classroom because they're a
seven-year-old little boy that we're
told you need to sit in that chair and
sit still for eight hours doing these
worksheets and when they can't we tell
them they're dysfunctional or we have
these young girls who just you know
because ADHD is expressed differently in
young women and and and they check out
and we Pat them on the back and say way
to go you sat quietly through class
right we take these kids and we stick
them in these very artificial
environments and then if they roll
outside of the bell curve we blame them
for them and then we have well-meaning
heartbroken parents saying what do I do
now right or
we have I would say moderately informed
parents that say this doesn't feel right
I know in my gut this isn't right
um but I don't know what to do and so
I've begun saying hey you got to take
some of this education into your own
hands and then I pick up your book and
it's got sections I'd love to talk about
teaching kids
self-regulation I because that I mean
then you're teaching a kid What a
Feeling is and what an emotion is and
you're teaching teaching them that
mindful gap between stimulus and
response if you if we could teach kids
that you're talking like a global life a
world that is a different world right
tot totally doesn't have politicians
popping off at them you know how it gets
we can get sideways on that but let's
talk about how a single mom with two
kids how a truck driver who just wants
to be a better a more present father how
do they teach their kids
self-regulation well I'm yeah I love how
you framed that question and that whole
background that you gave there because
the one of the main reasons I wrote this
book was because we need to be able to
help parents to be able to do this the
single most important way of helping our
children do this or helping a parent to
help our children is for a parent to
know how to regulate themsel so it
begins with if if we have to start
addressing the Mental Health crisis in
both adults and children but let's talk
about children first is we have to be
able to help a parent help themselves
because the stress of the parent will go
through to the child oh say that again
say that again cuz uh we're going to
preach for a second say that one more
time the the anxiety or stress that a
parent feels is picked up directly by
the child it goes straight through the
child so priority number one and biggest
mental health support is to educate
parents in helping them to say messy
parenting is so normal you don't have to
curate your life like we see on the
influencer sort of world that we live in
now we have to recognize that we've got
our own baggage we've been parented by
parents that have their baggage we have
the right to honor our own trauma from
our own parenting that may have been
good and bad everyone comes to you every
parent no matter how well intentional
you're going to mess your kids up in
some way you messed up in some way that
is just the reality and for some it's
obviously way worse than others you know
in extreme situations but we need you
know there's certain things that we've
got to deal with that we haven't and it
comes true to our kids so that's a
reality and we're going to make those
mistakes so if we can accept that
upfront and give ourselves compassion
and kindness and realize all right
that's I have to honor my story not not
that I'm dishonoring my parents because
they're someone else's daughter and son
you know so therefore you know it's um
they someone else's daughter or son
whatever so therefore we have to look at
two things we have to honor our story of
the impact of our parenting on us as
parents and that does and recognize that
we need to honor our parent stories and
that a lot of what we experienced it has
affected us they also had to deal with
does that make sense we got absolutely
it doesn't mean that if you say okay
this is this was this has come through
from my own nurturing you're not just
honoring your parent you are honoring
them because they also went through
their stuff but you also have the right
to work on your stuff so that's very
important because parent guilt is a
massive massive issue and the thing that
you've got to be perfect parents is
absolute nonsense because parenting is
not going to be perfect all the time as
we all know okay so that means that I
need to be able to know how to deal with
my own stuff so when I'm reactive to my
kids for example um you as a truck
driver that example you gave or just
wanting to be a good parent and help
their child or Mom and Mom Dad family
big family life things happening maybe
your child's going through something and
there's a pattern happening and this
child's very reactive or crying a lot
and you find yourself reacting to their
reactivity and then you feel guilty
because you say things and then you try
and suppress it so you're worried so
there's this thing going on where the
child sees the mom or dad or both being
very anxious and but not saying anything
but so they don't understand the parents
reaction and they can see cuz they can
read through they can read body language
better than a than a than a an adult so
us not being authentic with what we
experiencing pretending oh everything's
fine when it's not fine is terrible for
a child cuz they think that there's
something they've done because they can
see you not fine so bottom line be
authentic about how you are feeling
obviously age appropriate level so if
you're having a bad day and you come in
and you and you really worried about
what the teacher phoned you about while
you were driving home and the patterns
of behavior that you seeing in your
child plus the pressure of work and
pressure of life and finances or
whatever and you walk in the door and
you actually very irritable reactive um
defensive as a as a parent and you just
don't do that first connection with your
kids as you come back very well and
there's a maybe an argument and you say
things you wish you didn't say or you
just whatever you just this and you feel
guilty and you got to be they's say that
that's happening you need a first work
on yourself and the first thing is to
say okay I've had I and you're walking
you yellow at your kids the first thing
is to say to your kids okay I'm sorry I
am feeling emotion signal you describe
signal you go through as a process and
I'll explain what that is after I've
explained the process I'm going to
demonstrate it first you say to your
kids I'm so sorry I am so frustrated
today I'm so worried and I'm so
frustrated I'm so frustrated because I
just can't seem to fix this issue that's
going on um with with you I'm trying to
help you but I don't know how to do it
and I'm really worried about you and I'm
also very tired because work's been very
demanding the last few days so I'm
that's how so i' say how I'm feeling
then I say it made me I kind of in that
sentence analyze I I talked about
emotions I talked about the fact that
I'm that I'm Snappy whatever cuz I
snapped at the kids or whatever I'm
giving this example behaviors um my body
was very tense so when I spoke to you I
did this and I my and I was scary and my
face was scary that's my body reacting
to how I'm feeling and you know what I
said and I'm my my Outlook my
perspective how I'm seeing this
situation how I'm looking at life today
is that I'm really feel don't know what
to do do now you've you've identified
and you've outlined for the child or
children and for yourself you've done
the most phenomenal things you've
authentically helped the child
understand that adults also battle
you've been honest and authentic you've
made them feel better because they they
think oh it's not me it's Mom so you've
activated empathy or it's Dad or
whatever they're going through something
it's okay they you know they it's okay
to be messy so you've given them
permission to to be messy cuz life is
messy they don't have to suppress their
feelings I love it and I want to point
out something you said that's really I
think Super critical that that parent
that you described that exhausted mom
coming in the door didn't immediately
say you kids y'all are doing this and
you're doing this and you're doing this
the language you used was very specific
which is I'm feeling this and I'm
feeling that and one of the things I
think we do is we often cast the
emotional regulation of the adults in
the house on to our kids it's your job
to make sure I'm not mad it's your job
to make sure I'm not upset and kids
can't carry that weight and so there's
something powerful about saying I'm
worrying because I can't solve this
problem not that you're making me
worried or that you're making me mad or
you're hurting my feelings you're a kid
you don't have that kind of power I'm
not going to give you that kind of power
in my life but I'm struggling CU I can't
solve this and I think that's such a
powerful switch for parents to flip if
they will take ownership of how they
feel and how they experience their own
homes hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful non-anxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
all right we are back thanks for
sticking around after my conversation
with Dr Leaf don't forget save your
holidays go to john.com and pick up
questions for humans the Thanksgiving
deck the Christmas deck and the
grandparents and kids not to mention all
the ones with couples and dating and
teenagers all of them wherever you
happen to be in life I got you I got you
don't do holidays by yourself this year
and especially with a bunch of news
channels and screens everywhere turn it
off remember why you like your family or
be crystal clear as to why you don't
right all right as we wrap up today's
show it's one of one of the greatest
songs ever written by the great
Fleetwood Mac song's called
Landslide and it goes like this I took
my love and I took it down I climbed a
mountain and I turned around
and I saw my reflection in the snow
covered Hills till Landslide brought me
down mirror in the Sky What's Love Can
the child within my heart rise above can
I sail through these changing ocean
tides can I handle the season of my life
well I've been afraid to changeing cuz I
built my life around you but time makes
you Bolder even children get older and
like Kelly I'm getting older too much
much older I love you guys make good
choices see you
[Music]
soon